♪ (SOFT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Hi, my name is Carrie Coon,
and welcome
to the latest edition
of Mansion Row on 5th Avenue.
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
Bertha Russell's family,
newly minted by
the Transcontinental Railroad,
have arrived, and she wants
everyone to know it.
And so, she's built
this palatial estate,
in the hopes that
she'll attract the curiosity
of fancy New York society.
These fixtures,
the gilded walls,
the grand scale,
it's all designed
to signal to them that
she will not be ignored.
GEORGE RUSSELL:
They don't know we exist.
Well they will now.
CARRIE COON: Most of
the fixtures you see here
were inspired by,
or copied from,
the historic mansions
in Newport, Rhode Island.
This fireplace, for example,
is modeled after those
in The Breakers.
And of course, there's nothing
like a sweeping staircase
to put me right
in Bertha's shoes.
And what better showcase
is there for the beaded cape
of a long train?
Please,
come into the drawing room.
COON: The drawing room is one
of my favorite rooms on the set.
And not just because
of the Boldini-inspired portrait
of Bertha on the wall.
Portraits by Boldini were
very coveted status symbols,
and Bertha has hers
prominently displayed.
Most of the furniture
you see in this room
are antiques that
have been reupholstered.
Mirroring the cold limestone
of the exterior,
Bertha's interior also features
more limestone, marble,
ample gold leaf,
and bright colors designed to
emphasize the scale of the room.
These high ceilings
could swallow
the most intimidating adversary.
My goodness... How splendid.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
The columns you see here
in the dining room
were also fashioned
after those in The Breakers.
This tablecloth was fabricated
by a seamstress in Russia,
and based off of
our team's research.
Every detail on the set
was meticulously researched
and sourced
by Regina Graves and her team.
This red damask, for example,
was reprinted
by the original manufacturer
from an old file.
And, like her historical
counterpart, Alva Vanderbilt,
Bertha would've been involved
at every level
of decision-making.
We finished the gilding
in the ballroom, Mrs. Russell.
No, you think you have finished
the gilding, Mr. Kowalski,
but nothing is finished
'til I decide.
COON: Our production designer,
Bob Shaw,
says that Bertha's bedroom
is a tribute
to Alva Vanderbilt's bedroom
at the Marble House
in Newport.
It's filled
with antique trinkets,
historical reproductions.
If someone were to wander in
from the Brook House,
they might ask,
"Where's the sink?"
Betraying, once again,
the Russell's
extravagant wealth.
Whereas the Brook House would've
had sinks in the bedroom,
and a shared common toilet,
the Russell's have
their toilet and bathtub
in one modern bathroom.
I know, it's shocking.
Alleluia.
Let the trumpets sound.
Thank you for joining me
on this tour of Bertha's
extraordinary home.
♪ (MUSIC SWELLS) ♪
♪ (MUSIC SOFTENS) ♪